bonjour vous avez tous entendu parler
d'einstein et sa théorie de la
relativité
vous avez sûrement aussi entendu parler
de darwin et sa théorie de l'évolution
vous avez probablement aussi entendu
parler de marie curie et de sa
radioactivité mais avez vous entendu
parler d'alain turing et de sa machine
universel ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
l'ordinateur il ya un peu plus d'un
siècle
alan turing à dessiner sur un bout de
papier le modèle de ce qui allait
devenir notre ordinateur il appeler ça
une machine universel dans le sens où
elle pouvait tout faire elle pouvait
nous permettre d'envoyer des messages de
faire des calculs de jouer aux échecs
peut-être de découvrir des vaccins
bientôt de conduire des voitures ou des
avions et tout un tas de choses
alain turing c'est aussi des codes
secrets
c'est ce sont des algorithmes du vivant
ce qu'il a appelé la morphogénèse et
c'est aussi ce qu'on appelle aujourd'hui
et qui est très à la mode
l'intelligence artificielle alain turing
c'est une vie très mouvementée une vie
hors du commun un héros des temps
modernes
turing c'est aussi le père de
l'intelligence artificielle et c'est le
thème principal du livre
turing à la page il ya dans un transat
qui vous propose du coude d'année turing
c'est pas la place cette année mais au
moins vous accompagner pendant cet été
pour essayer de mieux comprendre
calmement tranquillement une façon très
compréhensible les fondements de la
théorie de l'intelligence artificielle
selon alan turing notamment avec des
liens avec la manière dont
l'intelligence artificielle est
développée aujourd'hui et ce qui a été
vraiment incroyable en écrivant ce livre
c'est de voir toutes les connexions
qu'il ya toutes les connexions très
naturel qu'il ya entre les raisonnements
de d'alan turing et toutes sortes de
domaines divers et variés et bien sûr
les mathématiques puisqu'à la base à
l'informatique de chiang a été inventé
pour les mathématiques mais également
avec d'autres domaines comme la
philosophie du langage comme la
psychologie des enfants encore comme la
biologie de la morphogénèse tout ça a
été vraiment mis en avant par alan
turing qui a proposé une vision trek et
algorithmique qui a complètement
bouleversé notre façon de voir le monde
et en particulier l'apprentissage et le
raisonnement c'est vraiment une
introduction à tous ces concepts que
rachid guerraoui et moi vous proposons
dans ce livre publié chez dunod